il vous arrive de ne plus avoir trop
vous embête vous avez des problèmes de
coeur ont du reste venait d'en poser
votre question devant notre caméra et
j'essaierai de vous répondre
un ami j'ai l'impression que c'est
mélanie certitude qu'il ya une personne
qui une femme qui me court après c'est à
dire une personne que je rencontre
plusieurs fois on en a travaillé sur un
projet ensemble et donc ce projet s'est
cassé la figure et bizarrement je la
revois souvent quand je vais le sort de
la fac je la vois deux trois fois quand
je vais prendre un museau jour je les
rencontre elle aussi elle leur parle de
ce projet abarth ekwalla et elle m'a
proposé de venir dîner avec elle j'ai
revu une autre fois à côté de chez moi
alors ce qu'il ya c'est la 45 ans mais
bon elle est bien pour son âge quoi
beaucoup de charme en plus mais bon
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse
me demandez pas ce que vous voulez faire
vous savez très bien vous avez envie de
succomber au charme de cette dame c'est
un tellement de mal pour vous rencontrer
et ceux qui mouillent chicane
c'est que vous vous demandez si c'est
bien le faire et bien sachez que
beaucoup de vos camarades dont certaines
ont succombé aux charmes d'une dame de
47 ans d'ailleurs vous n'avez qu'à lire
l'éducation sentimentale chez vous le
rouge noir et vous verrez c'est très
souvent pratiquée vous y découvrirez
d'ailleurs tout en misant de la bonne
littérature que les dames de 45 ans sont
plutôt plus douce que vos petites
camarades de l'habituel qu'elles font
des cadeaux éventuellement et qu'elle
vous apprennent beaucoup de choses ne me
demandez pas quelle chose vaut après
c'est vous qui allez me dire lesquels
quand vous maigrirez pour me remercier
en france là je suis venu pour demander
des renseignements sur mon mari mais
j'ai mon mari y arriver alors je sais
qu'on a tant besoin d'amour et eads se
coucha premiers kills en aura - fera son
entrée en action
bonjour sont durs envers et moi j'estime
que je suis content je pourrais avoir un
peu avec lui mais je way qui saigne pour
pour ça ainsi quelqu'un ou bon c'est
fini avec lui je pense très souvent
madame d'amour j'ai l'impression que
votre question au cache une crainte
alors sachez d'abord que la courbe
d'activité sexuelle d'un homme et d'une
femme n'est pas du tout la même
un homme voit ses capacités d'amendé qui
n'eut et quelquefois même à partir de 25
ans alors qu'une femme de 40 ans souvent
en 500 et vous avez que si les sportifs
à 40 ans ne bat pas des records
comment voulez vous que les gens qui ne
sont pas sportifs en bateau si plus tard
d'autre part les hommes sont des petites
mécaniques assez fragile quand on est
fatigué d'un vide hormis une faconde
rivage
pourquoi essayez vous de l'empêcher de
dormir alors que vous auriez peut-être
intérêt à le réveiller gentiment quand
il fait sa sieste
un thé un petit gâteau quand il se
réveille le samedi matin ou dimanche
matin
un bon petit déjeuner et puis souvenez
vous d'une chose ce qu'on exige dans
l'amour ne l'obtiens jamais il ne faut
que suggérez
la france vit là un problème vraiment
chaque fois que je fais l'amour je crée
beaucoup
et d'ailleurs je me demande si c'est
normal mais je peux vraiment pas m'en
empêcher
et en général les hommes a été je fais
l'amour ça les dérange énormément à ce
titre imagine que je fais semblant que
c'est faux que je joue la comédie
parce que c'est pas vrai du tout et
d'ailleurs le petit copain que j'ai en
ce moment m'a dit m'a dit que si ça
continue et oui il pourrait pas faire
l'amour avec moi parce que ça gêne
énormément
et puis vraiment je ne sais pas je me
demande si si je devrais il avertit
enfin leur dire que je suis comme ça
quoi
mais je sais pas je suis pas si normal
permettez moi d'abord mademoiselle de
vous féliciter pour votre vitalité si
vous amenez le nombre de jeunes femmes
qui en sont encore parce qu'on n'a pas
trouvé leur fameux point g à nous
renouveler par politesse
vous vous sentiriez tout à fait bien
notre part je vous félicite puisque
votre petite amie a su trouver les
moyens d'exalter votre sensibilité si
particulière
mais moi je vous propose une chose
jusqu'à maintenant vous étiez sincère en
criant et ça dérangeait ce jeune homme
mais maintenant je vous propose de ne
pas être sincère c'est à dire de notre
patrie des essais libres 2 voulu crise
et d'être silencieuse pendant qu'il
pourra ainsi en fait jouir de votre
compagnie
et puis vous verrez le retenir un
plaisir on ne supprime pas
nécessairement et 6 me à force d'essayer
d'être calme
vous finissez par trouver la
satisfaction qu'il y à a explosé à la
fin c'est bien ce grand cri et fera
plaisir parce que vous lui aurait donné
quelques inquiétudes sur ses capacités
et bien si vous avez d'autres problem et
vous en avez sûrement
écrivez moi